[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal sur tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 4 février voici
les titres de cette édition
le théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille ce soir le spectacle
les diables de michel schweizer et de la
compagnie l'oiseau mouche à cette
occasion une conversation croisé théâtre
et handicap est proposé tout à l'heure
avant la représentation
la page dédiée aux élections municipales
à villepreux il sera candidat pour un
troisième mandat stéphane mirambeau
conduira la liste ensemble
allons plus loin dans une ville miné par
les tensions entre élus et puis 65
communes labellisées villes et villages
fleuris en 2019 la cérémonie annuelle
d'attribution se dérouler en fin de
semaine dernière à saint cyr l'école et
c'est derrière avec ce reportage que
nous débutons ce journal les yvelines
seule collectivité à avoir le titre de
département fleuri en ile de france
elle aide les communes à bénéficier de
ce label villes et villages fleuris
marylène iapichino 65 communes
labellisées dans les yvelines en 2019 le
département est d'ailleurs le seul à
avoir la distinction le département
fleuri d'île de france engagée depuis 45
ans et d'adp les communes à accéder à
leur première fleur avec un système de
pétales avant de se présenter à la
région nous accompagnons les communes
progressivement en les récompensant au
fur et à mesure de leur progression et
au cinquième pétales nous estimons que
la ville ou le village est prêt à être
présenté au jury régional pour recevoir
sa première fleur mais par contre on
manque un petit peu de communes rurales
les communes rurales sont trop timide
trop timoré alors qu'elles font parfois
des choses extraordinaires avec très peu
de moyens des communes rurales qui ne
sont que 21% à participer à ce label
et parmi elles vont en ville de gaillard
commune de 120 habitants qui vient
justement d'obtenir son cinquième est
allée sera ainsi présenté au jury
régional
en 2020 le fruit d'un travail créatif on
a créé un jardin potager un verger en
fait des endroits sympathiques où les
gens puissent venir
ils se rencontrent et quoi bien sûr plus
que les pétales le département se
démarque par ses trophées spéciaux pour
continuer d'encourager la dynamique des
villes et villages déjà fleuri
la commune de coignières de fleurs au
compteur a remporté les trophées coeur
de ville et sa mairie fleury émaillage
sans trottoirs et pieds de murs fleuris
la récompense d'une équipe d'une
quinzaine de personnes ça permet
vraiment de relever des défis en
permanence et ce qui permet d'avancer ça
c'est certain c'est vraiment une
incitation à toujours faire mieux
113 communes yvelinois sont inscrits
dans le dispositif villes et villages
fleuris pour la saison 2010 les
inscriptions label et au trophée du
département s'ouvriront en avril mais
pour des visées du jury tout l'été parmi
les villes labellisées 9 ce dont se sont
sont de saint-quentin-en-yvelines magny
les hameaux fait partie des trois
communes à obtenir une deuxième fleur un
spectacle ce soir au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la compagnie
de l'oiseau mouche présente sa 50e
création les diables représentation ce
soir et demain à 20h30 et ses mises en
scène par vous michel schweizer bonsoir
tafer bonsoir alors ce mardi soir juste
avant cette représentation il y a à 19
heures une conversation croisé qui est
organisée sur le thème théâtre et
handicap et c'est en collaboration avec
le théâtre
eurydice esat de plaisir on en parle
aussi avec richard leteurtre bonsoir
bonsoir le directeur de ce théâtre pour
le présenter c'est un établissement de
service et d'aidé par le travail ou les
une soixantaine de personnes en
situation de handicap psychique y sont
accompagnés pour exercer notamment dans
les métiers du spectacle la question
alors qu'il sera posée ce soir dans
cette conversation croiser l'une des
questions sur lui en aura plusieurs sait
comment faciliter l'accès à la culture
pour ces personnes en situation de
handicap
c'est ça c'est ça c'est la question
centrale on la développe
quels sont les objectifs du coup les
hôtels et converser à permettre à toutes
les personnes en situation de handicap
de pouvoir accéder à la culture soit en
tant que spectateur soit en tant
qu'acteur et la question que va se poser
enfin qui est posée là avec les diables
qui sont représentés ce soir c'est
comment des personnes des artistes en
situation de handicap peuvent pouvoir
avoir accès à des plateaux de théâtre
telles que le théâtre de saint quentin
scène nationale puisque on précise que
pour la compagnie de l'oiseau mouche
c'est une troupe de comédiens en
situation de handicap il ya 23
comédien qui composent cette troupe et
c'est unique en france le fait qu'il y
ait que des comédiens en situation de
handicap
oui nesat comme ça oui je crois que
c'est le seul salon en france et puis il
ya le théâtre eurydice qui était aussi
un esat avec des coyotes
en fait il y en a quatre en cinq ans
maintenant en france mais c'est vrai que
l'oiseau mouche et le premier et le plus
connu probablement des esat artistique
et culturelle mais on le disait cette
compagnie qui présente sa 50e création
il ya déjà une renommée à son actif
pourtant il n'empêche que certaines
portes restent encore fermés aujourd'hui
notamment la la programmation du
festival d'avignon la programmation in
qui n'a pas retenu les diables dans
cette programmation ce pas c'est qu'il y
avait déjà une compagnie
qu'on peut dire madame madeleine loire
inquiets qui est en bretagne qui est
déjà venu plusieurs fois présenté des
choses
vignon donc voilà on veut dire que ça
arrivait pas au bon moment cette crise
sur un an mars dernier mais c'est vrai
que sur une méritait de gagner
visibilité à travers le présence au
festival d'avignon pour cette grande
tenue ça c'est clair
d'autres questions seront bien sûr
évoqué ce soir notamment qu'est ce que
peut créer une personne en situation de
handicap comment vous travaillez vous
justement au théâtre eurydice de plaisir
sur cette question de la création en
tant que metteur en scène j'ai pas
l'impression de travailler tellement
différemment ce qui nous porte
je pense qu'on partagera sa ce qui nous
importe c'est le projet c'est ce qu'on a
envie de dire
artistiquement et on le dit avec les
personnes avec qui on travaille avec les
comédiens avec qui on travaille qui je
répète sont de véritables comédiens
professionnels
même s'ils n'ont pas fait le
conservatoire ils ont une pratique
depuis 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 25 ans pour
certains ils ont travaillé avec des
pleins de metteur en scène différents
finalement ils ont appris leur métier
de cette manière là et joue dans sur les
scènes y connaissent les enjeux de du
texte et de la répétition ils se
connaissent les enjeux de la dead line
ils connaissent les enjeux de du rapport
au public du stress qui va avec si on
regarde l'envoyé spécial on voit
beaucoup la question du stress mme qui
finalement il est partagé par tous les
comédiens qu'elle quel qu'il soit donc
finalement il n'y a pas tant de
différences pour l'artiste pour le
metteur en scène pour travailler avec
eux moi je trouve par contre il ya le
regard du public qui peut qu'il peut
vraiment différé quoi et surtout est
gérée sait comment ça fait bouger les
esthétiques c'est un peu ça mais ce
festival imago ce que vous êtes d'accord
justement avec eux complètement changé
j'ai passé plusieurs semaines avec eux
je te rassure en mars dernier à l'issue
de cette création qui s'est plutôt très
bien passée et cette expérience
finalement avec eux cette collaboration
avec eux après j'ai eu du mal j'ai eu du
mal pendant quelques semaines à me dire
que j'allais pouvoir facilement
retravailler des personnes ordinaires
c'était un petit peu compliqué pour moi
depuis ça c'est nettoyer mais voilà
c'est vraiment se retrouver dans un
effort de collaboration dans un milieu
de gamme assez particulier où tout et
tout est redistribué c'est-à-dire notion
de tant de frustrations des formes
imaginaires de l'interpolation etc
donc c'est vrai c'est une sacrée
expérience ça a été une sacrée
expérience pour l'invitation qui m'a été
fait qu'on précise alors que la
compagnie l'oiseau mouche est une troupe
qui n'a pas de metteur en scène attitré
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vous à
travailler avec eux vous le dites vous
dites une expérience enrichissante mais
avant qu est ce qui vous a poussé ce que
je suis quelqu'un qui aime bien faire
des expériences c'est à dire mettre le
pied dans des choses que je ne connais
pas c'est comme ça que je se sentent je
me développe je maintiens dans une belle
verticalité un terme d'humanisme et donc
je oui oui quand je suis venu et en 2016
faire un premier stage d'approché par
rapport à cette compagnie
et puis janeiro fait un autre en 2017 et
en 2018 j'ai dit au directeur de
l'époque stéphane frimat que j'étais
prêt à faire une création avec sept de
ses comédiens puisqu'il est bien fallu
faire une audition et sur les 23 jeunes
invitait que cette ce qui est déjà
beaucoup
or les diables les diables qui sera
présenté ce soir et demain évoque le
métier de comédien il interroge aussi
sur le rôle de spectateur et je crois
que vous avez demandé à vos comédiens de
faire comme s'il ne jouait pas c'est ça
j'ai ça se sait un peu inhérents ma
manière de travailler oui je j'avais
devant moi vraiment des comédiens
professionnels avec des automatismes de
comédiens et cetera et cetera des choses
déjà un tout petit peu formaté sur
l'ancienneté des uns et des autres et
donc je leur expliquais que oui dont le
travail que je développe j'aime bien que
les personnes soient plus près d'elle
même sous une forme d'authenticité et de
vérité assez troublante en leur
expliquant que je réduis comme ça le
l'écart qui peut exister entre la scène
et la salle
et donc on a développé une forme ou ses
comédiens finalement on y voit d'abord
comme des humanités et puis
effectivement on peut décéder à certains
moments le métier qu'ils ont des degrés
variables et puis aussi le oui lol la
lecture qu'ils ont du monde le rapport
qu'ils ont au monde qui est qui
s'exprime un peu à travers certains
moments de cette pièce voilà pour
quelques clés pour la suite venait tout
à l'heure à cette conversation croisés
elle débuta à 19h01 ce mardi soir au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et je précise
que ce sera suivi à 20h30 du spectacle
les diables une deuxième représentation
est également prévue demain mercredi
toujours à 20h30 merci à richard
l'auteur merci à michel schweizer d'être
passé en plateau pour en parler c'est
une start up en plein développement une
success story en devenir a planté à
montigny le bretonneux exacte des exodes
games est un jeu un éditeur de jeux de
société créée en 2010 est cette société
connaît une forte croissance grâce au
développement notamment de son jeu de
jurassic world développé en
collaboration avec universal les détails
de nicolas d'andré c'est la nouveauté et
le succès 2019 d'exode games le jeu
jurassic world 2 développé par cette
start up créée en 2017 est installé à
montigny le bretonneux spécialisée dans
l'édition de jeux de société elle s'est
associée à universal pour créer ce
wargame vous allez créer votre faction
développer votre votre deck de cartes
pour constituer votre armée et faire un
scénario de
que ce soit juste faire un objectif ou
alors affronter humains et dinosaures ou
incarner un dinosaure ce qui est assez
rare grâce à jurassic world exode games
a multiplié par trois son chiffre
d'affaires un demi million d'euros
récoltés avec les ventes
les équipes sont passées de 3 à 6
collaborateurs avec notamment l'arrivée
en avril 2010 9,2 marion graphistes
designers ça peut être de la position
texture ça peut être de la créa complète
en imaginant un visuel de cartes ça peut
être la mise en place d'éléments
par exemple pour une boîte de jeu ou ce
genre de choses c'est assez varié en
fait n'est par exemple aller chercher de
la texture des remous d'air brûler des
arbres de la pierre et tout assembler
ces éléments pour créer un environnement
on va dire logique et en même temps
assez esthétique exode games a lancé
aussi exode conception pour les
prototypes et des figurines 3d et exode
studio pour de futurs projets on a
quelques pistes pour développer si
certains jeux en jeux vidéo voir en film
d'animation
donc on essaie de toucher à tout ce qui
est vraiment le métier de l'intervenant
qui tourne autour du jeu en général ou
d'animation et on espère que d'ici cinq
ans oui on aura développé un studio de
jeux vidéo
objectif pour x games dans les
prochaines années a réalisé 10 à 15 % de
croissance par an il était de passage
sur tv 78 arnaud tsamère a été reçu par
mélanie poquet dans l'émission vais y
paie l'humoriste qui s'est fait
connaître grâce à notamment à l'émission
on n'demande qu'à en rire est originaire
des yvelines cet attrape qu'il est qu'il
s'est formée au sein de la compagnie
d'improvisation déclic théâtre une
rencontre lors d'un spectacle à lui vs
cul qui a changé sa vie écoutez je ne me
doutais pas que en allant voir ce
spectacle à la fac donc à 300 millions
je me doutais pas que ça allait changer
ma vie ouais mais au sens littéral
vraiment sache qui vous a plu qu'est ce
qui vous a fait ce déclic
bah c'est en fait quand j'ai vu ce
spectacle déjà je me suis beaucoup marré
et puis c'était très ludique
il y avait plein de sol les matchs
d'impro ces deux équipes avec dédé des
maillots de hockey sur glace un arbitre
c'était très coloré très très
très ludique fait et je voyais des gens
vraiment prendre beaucoup de plaisir à
faire ce spectacle et nous spectateurs
ont ri aux larmes
je me suis dit tiens c'est quelque chose
je savais qu'il y avait un cours d'un
pro il y avait quelque chose qui était
organisée à la fac donc dès le lendemain
je suis allé m'inscrire et et c'est là
que j'ai rencontré les gens qui
m'accompagnent encore aujourd'hui qui
allait devenir ma ma plus que des amis
ma famille à artistique et voilà et puis
et puis ça a changé ma vie puisque
quelques années plus tard j'ai décidé
d'en faire mon métier même une émission
à retrouver en intégralité ce mardi soir
à 20h sur tv 78 rediffusion également
vendredi à 20 heures une émission à
retrouver aussi sur tv 78 points comme
être celui ou celle qui réussit à
franchir le plus grand nombre de blogs
ce week-end verticale art à montigny le
bretonneux organisait son deuxième
ardeurs bolzer stronger une compétition
d'escaladé près de 200 passionnés se
sont raf affrontés pour le plaisir
retour avec mélanie poker et 50 bloc à
gravir à réaliser les pratiquants
seniors 2 blocs s'étaient donné
rendez-vous ce week-end à montigny le
bretonneux
les adhérents du groupe verticale art et
des passionnés
tu vas au max mais mais ça va et les
boissons champagne
mais ce qui compte c'est implicite qui
deux ans et que ben je participe à
toutes les compétitions qui séjourne à
la gt pas pas forcément prêts à voir
cette difficulté là après je crains que
de + 4 mois mais je m'attendais à
pouvoir sortir des blocs un peu plus un
peu plus dur c'est un esprit composition
trets a développé et j'aime ça le
dépassement de soi la motivation
l'entraînement qui est toujours dur et
puis la réussite des fois aussi et la
compétition surtout sept niveaux de
difficulté des novices aux experts près
de 200 personnes se sont confrontés au
deuxième quart d'heure boulder stronger
un contexte initiée par la salle
verticale arbres de montigny le
bretonneux des passages les problèmes à
réaliser dans une salle d'escaladé
succès des parcours d'escaladé qui
culmine à 4 mètres de haut du coup on en
enlève toute la partie à hong hong et
baudriers d'escaladé qui s'arrache du
short chaussons d'escaladé et l'objectif
est d'arriver par un chemin de prises
2000 euros de lots ont été répartis
entre les différents vainqueurs une
troisième édition est déjà en train de
se préparer
[Musique]
la page dédiée aux élections municipales
pour refermer cette édition il a annoncé
sa candidature en juin 2018 rodolphe
barry conduit la liste ensemble agissons
pour guyancourt et poursuit sa campagne
marylène iapichino et mélanie poker il
tracte tous les week-ends devant les
commerces l'équipe de la liste ensemble
agissons pour wii en cours menée par
rodolphe barry considère ce rendez-vous
comme incontournable pour venir à la
rencontre des habitants
ça se passe plutôt bien on a un bon
accueil de la part des dieux en courtois
donc tout le monde nous prend nos tracts
et puis certains s'arrêtent pour
échanger globalement franchement on a on
a vraiment un très très bon accueil
une liste sans étiquette et indépendante
d'anciens membres de la majorité ont été
séduits notamment par la volonté de
faire des efforts pour la jeunesse et la
démographie locale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui tous les
citoyens sont en attente justement de sa
d'avoir une place dans la vie de leur
ville dans la ville la société est plus
que ce soit de trois personnes qui
décident pour eux une démocratie locale
avec la volonté de créer des conseils de
quartier mais aussi un accent mis sur le
développement durable avec un maire
adjoint dédié et l'élaboration ou d'éco
quartier enfin le programme qui sera
bientôt dévoilée souhaite mettre
l'accent sur la tranquillité publique
pour nous la tranquillité publique ça
commence par la prévention c'est
incontournable prévention mais aussi
renforcement de
du nombre de caméras de vidéoprotection
et renforcement aussi du nombre de
policiers municipaux
plusieurs mouvements politiques de
centre droit lui ont apporté son soutien
non demandées mais acceptée par le
candidat qui ne les affiche sera
cependant pas dans ses tracts dans la
commune de guyancourt quatre autres
listes sont déclarés à ce jour à
villepreux c'est un duel à 5 aussi qui
se profile pour ces élections
municipales bonsoir stéphane denis
rambaud savez ce que vous êtes le maire
sortant de la commune vous serez
candidat à un troisième mandat vous qui
avez été élu pour la première fois en
2008 et vous conduirez la liste ensemble
allons plus loin vous indiquez pourtant
en septembre ne pas vouloir vous
représentez suite aux défections de
nombreuses défections qu'il ya eu au
sein de votre conseil municipal pourquoi
changer d'alu pourquoi il y aller
finalement tout simplement ce canton et
maire d'une ville
moi j'ai travaillé sur un projet en deux
en 2008 tout est long tous prend du
temps il ya déjà des choses encore à
faire ça c'est la première des raisons
la deuxième des raisons on voit et
beaucoup de maires le le dise le
deuxième mandat le mandat qui vient de
passer de 2014 à 2020 a été extrêmement
durs donc il ya eu des résultats qui ont
été obtenus sur la sur la ville
évidemment mais on se rend compte que
certaines promesses certaines choses
pourraient être faites et pourrait
mettre à mal ses différents donc on
rentre dans une période de grande
difficulté et je pense qu'un gars
expérimenté doit être là pour rester le
seul maître à bord et puis la troisième
des choses je dois je dois vous le dire
il ya tellement une personne qui ont
tout fait pour je ne me représente pas
moi j'aime pas qu'on décide pour moi et
mon chèque voulu simplement dire je suis
encore là et si je souhaite partir un
jour c'est moi qu'ils décideraient ces
tensions que l'on a senti dans la
commune notamment lors de votre
cérémonie de voeux vendredi dernier il
ya aussi ces deux plantes qui vous ont
visé pour harcèlement sexuel l'été
dernier qui sont toujours en cours
d'instruction actuellement ça ça ne vous
a pas fait hésiter dans le fait de vous
représenter
non parce que je remets en cause ces
différentes plein jeu remet en cause
tout ce qui a été dit il y a eu comme je
dis d'ailleurs si vous étiez là lors de
la cérémonie des voeux il y à une
instrumentalisation il y à une manip
manipulation je la rejette en bloc c'est
pour ça que je suis là je suis moi vous
savez je suis un maire qui dit la vérité
depuis 2008 c'est quelque chose dont
j'ai beaucoup de défauts sûrement mais
je dis là
vérité et je n'admets pas qu'on remette
en cause mon honneur et c'est pour ça
que je suis là et j'ai voulu aussi me
représenter des mois de septembre c'est
être un c'était important aussi à le
dire devant l'irresponsabilité de
certains élus qui étaient avec moi qui
sont en face de moi aujourd'hui qui ont
rendu leur l'ordre délégation et il n'y
avait qu'une seule chose à faire quand
on aime la ville comme je les aime
depuis 2008 il fallait être là fallait
reprendre les rênes et heureusement que
je les ai repris sinon je pense que la
ville soit dans une situation
extrêmement difficile encore aujourd'hui
quid de votre liste justement avec ces
départs que vous vous évoquez au sein de
votre équipe municipale est ce que vous
avez trouvé l'ensemble de vos colistiers
ce que cette équipe est complète mais
elle est complète et c'est une grande
satisfaction quand j'ai souhaité me
représenter repartir c'était aux
environs du 22 novembre
vous vous retrouvez vous regardez
derrière vous êtes tout seul est donc la
première priorité c'est évidemment de
constituer nice
elle s'est formée relativement vital
s'est accéléré au début de l'année 2020
nous sommes 35 s'était ouvert le 24
janvier donc en deux mois la liste c'est
composer avec des gens qui sont avec moi
qui me soutiennent totalement qui se
reconnaissent dans le projet j'ai voulu
défendre depuis 2008 est le bilan que je
porte aujourd'hui vous étiez stéphane
rambaud le premier maire des yvelines
vous revendiquez la république en marche
et l'om a justement investir un candidat
qui sera face à vous pour ces
municipales ça veut dire que c'est sans
étiquette que vous présentez faso aux
électeurs l'organisation je me ferais
représenter sans étiquette car c'est ce
que je défends depuis 2008 j'étais maire
sans étiquette pourtant j'étais membre
très actif de l'ump par contre je
défends des que gérer une ville ça
n'appartenait ni à la droite ni à la
gauche quand on parler d'école de parcs
etc y avoir différentes sensibilités au
sein de la teneur en oxyde pour ça que
j'ai j'ai en 2014 giraud fait exactement
la même chose qu'elle n'a aucune raison
de changer ce de changer cela et en 2020
je repars évidemment sans étiquette je
n'avais de toute façon demander le
soutien à personne ça c'est important
et quand les gens me rejoignent je leur
demande simplement de ned idée serait de
droite et d'extrême gauche je ne leur
demande pas leur courant de pensée ça ne
m'intéresse pas ce que je veux c'est
qu'il s'engage
est ce qu'ils se mobilisent pour la
réussite de la ville à mes côtés bien
sûr vos projets pour villepreux qu'elles
seront thiel est ce que c'est pour
suivre des projets déjà lancés en lancer
de nouveau pour ses éventuels
mandat oui alors ça c'est une des choses
la gestion d'une ville c'est une suite
et on peut pas tous les six ans moi je
trouve ça d'ailleurs très très drôle
qu'on dit alors quel est le programme
que vous allez faire comme si tous les
six ans fallait absolument qu'on se
remette autour d'une table et très vite
on fasse une grande 10 pour séduire le
plus possible de gens autour de projets
on écoute les gens on y tient ce sera
bien pour vous et les gens vous disent
oui et on est très contents de cela et
on met une grande liste
moi je leur ai juste une petite une
petite remarque que là dessus au cours
de mon premier mandat 2008 2014
il ya trois projets qui ont été faits
ces levés parc c'est la médiathèque etc
les premières acquisitions des terrains
de la pépinière et ben justement je ne
les avais pas mis dans mon programme
parce que ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui
un maire c'est pas de promettre
promettent promettre c'est de savoir
s'adapter à une situation de voir
quelles sont les opportunités et savoir
ce qu'il faut faire pour une ville donc
il ya le programme
c'est très bien moi je m'appuie sur le
bilan qui a été le mien que je porte
depuis 2008 et puis ce sera dans la
suite moi je ne vais pas arriver et
promettent des choses pour faire plaisir
aux gens comme ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui il ya des promesses qui sont
totalement irréalistes
elles ne pourront pas être fait tout
simplement ce que les finances de la
ville ne le permettent pas moi c'est la
suite quand je veut redynamiser le
village par un lieu qui sera à la fois
on va transférer l'école de musique on
va pouvoir mettre des animations à
pouvoir mettre des marchés on va
redonner de la vie et on va pouvoir dans
une autre zone de ce même endroit
pouvoir tester des choses sur un tiers
lieu il ya beaucoup de gens de ce
village qui nous disent vous ne pensez
plus à nous il n'ya plus de commerces
y a pas de commerce car n'y avait pas de
parking justement il ya du parti
aujourd'hui et on va pouvoir tester des
nouveaux commerces qui vont pouvoir être
mises en place à des tarifs extrêmement
extrêmement compétitif et la même chose
pourquoi je l'avais pas fait avant tout
simplement c'est pour ça que ça a du
sens le programme que nous allons porter
parce qu'il fallait construire la
nouvelle école pour pouvoir justement
utiliser ce lieu pour faire autre chose
et c'est tout cela la cohérence du
projet que je porte c'est de ne pas
promettre des choses nouvelles pour
faire plaisir mais donner du sens à un
projet par rapport à ce qui a été fait
et par rapport à ce qu'il faut faire
dans les prochaines années
dernière chose en 30 secondes je sais
que c'est très compliqué vous êtes
également attaqué parce que c'est
appliquez des quatre vice-présidents 50
en une ville prêt à intégrer cette
agglomération au cours de ce dernier
mandat quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration est ce qu'elle est
totalement réussi ce qu'elle est à
améliorer alors ça a été extrêmement
durs parce que moi c'est vrai je ne
viens pas de la de l'interco c'est
quelque chose nouveau qui était pour moi
pour la ville
j'ai mis du temps ça a créé quelques
tensions par contre aujourd'hui je
reconnais que les 12 maires ont su
s'entendre pour porter un projet commun
saint quentin en yvelines est une
réussite moi je suis ravi d'être le vice
président en charge du budget et des
finances car je sais que c'est le nerf
de la guerre je suis ravi d'être
vice-président et vêtements bien de
d'une intercommunalité qui porte le
développement économique et
l'environnement eau comme priorité par
contre et pour villepreux c'est vrai que
nous n'avions pas cette histoire avec
vous nous sommes au nord nous sommes
situés au nord de cette intercommunalité
il faudra encore travailler pour que les
villes creuser un individu proviennent
se sont réellement membres de cette
intercommunalité
c'est tout l'enjeu est également faire
mieux connaître saint quentin en
yvelines pour les prochaines années
merci stéphane mirambeau maire sortant
de villepreux candidats pour ces
élections municipales sur ce thème avec
la liste ensemble
allons plus loin quatre autres listes
seront en lice face à vous celle de
votre ex adjointe sylvie se démantèle de
jean baptiste à monique et 2 valérie
bain et de coureuses gaulle gaulle à
bord on retrouve bien sûr l'ensemble des
rendez vous de campagne sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme la direction
maurepas pour terminer afin de connaître
les enjeux de ces élections municipales
justement zone paris-ouest
reconstruction de la piscine
urbanisme et carrefour de la malle me
donne on fait le point avec mélanie
poker c'est un sujet qui a provoqué de
nombreux remous sur la précédente
mandature en avril 2015 le centre
nautique de maurepas reste porte close
son état d'usure et mis en avant pour
justification un site sportif qui
accueillait 170 mille utilisateurs par
an dont 40 mille scolaires des communes
de maurepas et l'encours et coignières
après de nombreux recours fait par
l'opposition le contrat de délégation de
service public a été signé le 6 janvier
2020 le projet doit sortir de terre en
une zone d'activités bientôt aussi zones
d'habitat paris ouest à cheval sur
maurepas et coignières va
progressivement changer de
âge un écoquartier de 800 logements
continuent de voir le jour
la première pierre du projet a été
symboliquement déposée en avril 2018 où
les vertes central des places de
stationnement matériaux biosourcés ou
encore domotique dans les logements
la résidence de maricourt doit être
livré fin 2020 le projet complet devrait
lui prendre fin l horizon 2030 des
constructions pour augmenter le taux de
logements sociaux mort pas en compte
actuellement 17 5%
la loi oblige les communes en avoir 25 %
un bétonnage présenté comme trop
importants par l'opposition autre enjeu
qui concerne plusieurs communes
carrefour de la malle me donne attendu
pour 2026 le réaménagement du site
prévoit son enfouissement la verrière
maurepas et coignières actuellement
séparés par la nationale 10 seront ainsi
rollier est d'ailleurs l'actualité des
élections municipales à retrouver dans
l'émission 7 8 politique ce soir sur tv
78 juste après ce journal est juste
après aussi l'émission 7,8 culture
présentée par aurélie ronces voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
non